for coctober there's a couple of ideas
floating around this this I think we
should do okay a dick or
sausage or saage that staffers put their
hands in a bag and guess if they're
touching a [__] or sausage yeah this one
I'm I actually yeah I know about this
one I love it you love it yeah I'm all
for that Mike says to me well yeah well
which staffer is going to put their hand
in there and I go Mike trainer
absolutely really yeah volunteered him
yeah I volunteered him they better be
mini sausages too we ain't got no big
sausages we need like breakfast links
yeah Mike yes you volunteered for this
right so you're gon to that's not how I
remember it I was actually specifically
asking to not do that I might have to
get Co again that's the worst thing you
could say on the show is that you don't
want to do something okay then bring it
on let's do it get your dicks out be a
team player yeah so Howard I guess like
we could do a table and we lay out
Richard's [__] my [__] a bunch of
sausages and then I guess Mike
blindfolded squeezes them all and he has
to decide
what's not I'm not doing this guys I
wouldn't go too far down the road on
that I'm actually gra what about JD then
that that makes more sense I think JD JD
probably be funnier yeah the problem
with the bits for cocktober is nobody
wants to like you guys are up for it but
nobody wants to touch your [__] and
stuff but JD might JD just pushed me you
bully
J you're you're you're a team player and
it's not a big deal well JD for the
sausage and Dick thing what if you wore
like rubber gloves listen I I have a
move that I would
immediately you'd probably squeeze the
hell out make a scream oh no well I'd
flick the hell out of it to no you don't
flick it CU then listen I play you want
me to play this game so bad that's on
playing now okay I'll get flicked I
don't give a [__]
wow I'm not really not looking to no I
don't want to do this no I think it
would be fun I think you're going go
ahead JD you'll go head to-head with
Gary okay oh Gary's gonna
do yeah well we got to have a
competition someone's got to win let's
see what Gary says Gary's definitely in
here here's how I'll be a team player if
JD and trainer will do it I will do it
as
Well's not here to do it though that's
if we're doing this we're doing you're
not doing it today God hold on hold on
you need time to promote something like
this uhhuh and just stage it we have to
set it up oh we need stingers and songs
everything yeah what do you say you guys
in or out are you going to just accept
the challenge or not it's a tough one I
know every you know everyone has their
own feelings about touching penis and
it's only Richard and S right there's no
strangers involved right just Richard no
only in the family yeah
exactly touching some touching strange
penis we're blindfolded for this
yeah I've seen
both it's a field game sque the feeling
it JD are you saying that if you're not
blindfolded you still couldn't tell the
difference between a dick and a sa no I
just no I don't want to I just feel
weiry and blindfolded in front of these
two God knows what the hell they'll do
we'll behave we'll behave uhhuh God damn
it Gary why do you have to say that man
he's a team player J all I say chall as
soon as I saw this today yes it's weird
to touch another guy's dick but it's
also ridiculously silly I just think
this is such a silly you and it's
Richard and Sal I know what it is I know
who like we touching the security guards
right Richard again I'm not going to
like touch it and rub it I will flick it
and I will see how you you're going to
lose oh my God for a bid I lose this
game no but JD you want to lose my kids
won't talk to me again if I [__] this up
well you want to win if you're going to
play you play to win you might get very
lucky you might only touch sausage
that's the other thing you don't know if
G if Gary's going to do it I'll [__]
do it with Gary
ni boy we both held out we could have
stopped this you son of a [__] it's not
going to keep
going all right J's in Gary's in Mike
I'll be curious to hear your solution to
all of this oh let me hear the final
pitch and then I'll decide we gave it to
you're in you're blindfolded you touch
the [__] and you figure out what your
sausage it's pretty no there's going to
be a prize all I want to hear the prize
you're OIC you keep your job oh
okay that's a good prize you get to keep
your job that is a good prize yeah yeah
happy cocktober Howard can you guess the
mass singer from the other week I'm
going to play it for you the other week
see if you yeah see if you can figure
this out ever since I was a young boy I
play the Silver Bow from Soo down to
Bright I must have played them all but I
ain't seen nothing like it in any
amusement Hall that death dop and
pickle play
[Applause]
me
I Mike Rapaport famous actor Mike
Rapaport yeah picture a giant pickle
calling Gary a gorilla here's Mike even
uh the co-host with the most Robin
Quivers couldn't figure me out because I
have the voice of a [__] Angel but I
I could pivot I could stay with this as
much as you want but I saw a very
disturbing distressing photograph of
Baba buy standing next to Elvis
Presley in Las
Vegas so much about this so much about
that photo kept me up at night it just
was like Elvis and an ape and like J JD
wants to tell you something Mike go
ahead JD I have a question uh if uh
would you like to participate in Dicker
sausage with me and Gary oh no that's a
good question you versus Gary versus JD
Howard I'm gonna tell you something
right now you sick
dick [__] you that ain't never happening
come are you afraid are you afraid that
JD is gonna beat
you let me Howard you sick animal I'm
never doing okay let me put it to you
this way Mike Mike let me ask you a
question I'm shocked that Gary's willing
to work this this hard I'm just suren
here's the question I love the idea of
you do you think JD or
Gary can feel a sausage or a [__] and do
you feel those guys will know better
than you that they will win or are you a
competitor who's going to take these two
on and show the world how you could beat
them how soon we forget how excuse me
how soon Excuse Me Howard how soon we
forget that I participated in a
painting October a couple years ago how
we forget old news old news this game
needs a old news we need a celebrity for
the game I think it's way more honorable
and I'm being serious to play in Coober
than to dress up like a pickle I'm just
being Franken or dress up like a pickle
and come in here and play the game yeah
and if you want to put on your pickle
costume now Robin now we're talking now
you're speaking my language here now
you're talking my language because
that's kind of like a con play type of
thing and then I could always I could
always say I was in character like I was
this was like a performance right now
we're
talk I like where your head's at it's a
competition go ahead go I love the idea
go ahead I love the idea I really do I
love the idea of him calling me a filthy
ape while Sal [__] is in his hand I like
that okay fair enough okay but to bring
to bring it back to my original thing um
lips is Howard there's a picture of Gary
and and Elvis but if you zoom in on the
picture the lips are ginormous per usual
the teeth are are are just they're
they're they're they're fantastic but
the gums are black he is his are his
gums
blackening you got at the picture and
you know where did you go to where did
you go to acting school I was never went
to an acting class I just uh what crazy
selftaught self selftaught is amazing
Gary says he came it's funny well Gary's
an actor too he acts like he works so
Gary you worry about those [__]
blackening gums those [__] charred
gums I I don't know what is it's a bad
photo yes don't don't change the topic
I'm talking about this is the greatest
role of your life I just have to know if
I have my A-list or as part of this game
youn are you going to take the Challenge
from Gary and JD in the cocktober event
of the century Howard listen I've done
so much for this show brought so much
absolutely absolutely I who did someone
just m mummer something in the
background I've done so much tell me
what you did
today what what have I done today yeah I
I brushed my key I'm waiting I BR man
I've manned up and I'm gonna be part of
this you want be be a team player I
don't care about what you did in the
past it's all about
now okay listen today Howard can shut up
teeth I don't I just need yes or no oh
man you're you're making it so
compelling because I love you and I love
the show um I have to run this up the
flag pole with my wife and and my team
my a my my I didn't ask my team I didn't
ask my wife Michael I made a decision
because she doesn't talk to you she
doesn't want to look at
you I'm gonna respect Mike I respect you
let me know take the 24 take what you
need and then let us know that's all
Fred's going to lose that mustard
really I'll get you a [__] he's
afraid he's going to lose that shitty
mustard commercial I'll get you a
[__] toothpaste commercial you stinky
[__] rotten I'll take it I'll take to
commercial you can't even let's save
let's save the let's save all this for
the game let's save it for the game all
right thanks Mike congratulations thank
you Mike rra aort
everyone